where i got my work ethic from  was the hours i had to spend learning  this  when you sit down and you're not smart  you have a disability yeah  and you still want to be at the top of  your class i didn't want to get by when  i realized that i can learn do hard work  and i can beat the valedictorian in  school but i got put in 10 hours more a  day than he does you know what kind of  strength comes from that when you're  sitting down that guy that that valerie  study for an hour and you know i caught  you  i caught you and i am dumb  but i have the work ethic to catch you  that's where david gaga's got really  invented yeah was at a kitchen table  with 20 spiral notebooks that were empty  and then three months later  yeah they were full